later today new york city mayor bill de
blasio is expected to lay out more
details for his plan to require all
private sector workers to be vaccinated
by december 27th and people are furious
here in new york city meanwhile
philadelphia will soon require proof of
vaccination to eat indoors in
restaurants or drink inside bars like
new york city but you know what a new
poll reveals most americans think it
should be illegal for companies to deny
service
or employment to the unvaccinated 51
percent
here with reaction fox news medical
contributor dr mark siegel uh dr siegel
good morning to you so we we know that
businesses uh with their with their
employees as part of their employment
services agreement they can pretty much
dictate whatever they want to
but when it comes to their customers
that's different
absolutely steve good morning and i
think the science is a factor here
because i think the public is learning
that it's a combination of factors that
are involved with protecting you first
of all let's look at new york city where
83 of adults over 18 are now fully
vaccinated so if you go into a public
space the chances are you're going to
encounter only vaccinated people number
one number two you know i think what got
people upset is customers as well what
about someone that got over covet and i
don't yet want to give them a vaccine
what about somebody that that gets a
rapid test that should be an option
that's on the table here i agree that
businesses have a right to keep their
spaces safe but how are they going to go
about that and where's the flexibility
we see in europe and in israel where
getting over cope it actually counts for
some immunity and again rapid testing
may be a better way to see who's at risk
i think that all factors in and in that
poll you mentioned steve 47 of democrats
were against this and 52 percent of
republicans and that was a thousand
people studied over just the last couple
of weeks so i think this is a current
public sentiment in philadelphia about
73 percent are vaccinated so it's a
little bit less but the more people you
get vaccinated in an area the safer the
area is i just was at the knicks and
with the knicks they check you on the
way in you can get a rapid test or a
vaccine either one and the whole arena
people are relaxing enjoying themselves
and no outbreaks have have been have
been traced to that whatsoever so it's
all about the overall public health
right um you know a lot of people who
have had covet or thought they had
coveted have said you know i i don't
need to do that because i've got natural
immunity you have written an op-ed for
the hill and the headline is natural
immunity can be dangerous try hybrid
immunity which essentially is
you've had covid
but you need a you need a shot
to boost it and so
explain why you think people who've had
covid need to get the shot
first of all
carlos del rio who's the president-elect
of the infectious disease society of
america i interviewed him recently and
he told me he doesn't like the term
natural immunity because it implies that
the immunity you get from covid is
better somehow than vaccinated immunity
steve all immunity is good all immunity
is natural no matter how you got there
it's good it's not good that you had
covet but if you had coveted and got
some immunity for it that's good but you
know what's really good multiple studies
around the world in everywhere from
qatar to johns hopkins to to oregon all
over the country and in new york here at
rockefeller multiple studies have shown
that if you get one shot of an mrna
vaccine pfizer or modern on top of
recovering from covid just one shot your
immunity is more substantial than if you
got vaccinated that's a really important
finding so we need both if you've had
covet get at least one shot please okay
especially government should allow for
that too especially get the shot if
you've had covet if you had coveted a
year ago because the immunity starts to
wash out
well that's also true by the way that's
also true
people count on that they said oh i had
it a year ago i never even got tested i
know i had it i had the symptoms you may
not have had it and it's very variable
from person to person and you're
absolutely right it washes out over time
one last point with the omicron variant
coming we're seeing a lot of
re-infections of those cases too so
that's another reason to get vaccinated
and to get boosted to get hybrid
immunity all right dr siegel thank you
very much for joining us live
thanks steve hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now